[Music]
i'm tim maudlin i'm a professor of
philosophy at nyu and the
founder and director of the john bel
institute for the foundations of physics
and i
am going to just give a a talk about
some work i've been doing very recently
within the last year
so
we live in space and and time in some
sense and space and time have some
structure
and
from antiquity from at least zeno
it's been thought that it might be that
space is a continuum
at
at its fundamental level or it might be
that space isn't that it's somehow
discrete or chunked up
and
there was some debate about this it was
seemed immediately obvious that you
couldn't tell just by off hand looking
what the structure of space and time are
at a fundamental level so we can ask in
particular are space and time infinitely
divisible
now according to euclid
they are because for any line segment
you can
divide it in half and then you can take
the half and divide it in half and you
get an infinite number of points
that way
and because of that if you
have a point on a line in euclidean
geometry there is no next point over no
matter how little you go over you've
skipped over points to get there
um and the same is true for direction so
you have in this image uh on the on the
left
a line with two end points and then a
middle point the red point and on the
right two directions and then the red
direction that lies between them in the
same way so by the same kind of
argumentation and you put in geometry
they're an infinite number of directions
at any point they're an infinite number
of points on any line but as i said
since antiquity it's been considered
well maybe that's not true
and
maybe at base space and time are
discrete in some way
and even so it could appear continuous
at everyday scales and that just seems
like a
simple thing to understand
your computer screen is made of pixels
it's discrete there are certain number
of pixels that come on on a certain
range of colors but because there are so
many of them at the scale you look at it
it looks continuous it looks like it
looks like kind of you put in geometry
now if you want to have a discrete
structure and that's what i've been
working on
you have to say all right what makes one
point
adjacent to
another that is if you have one point
and then literally the next one along
what gives them that relation and in
this kind of atomic geometry i've been
thinking about the answer is well you
have atomic one-dimensional elements so
we can think of points as atomic zero
dimensional elements and then you have
atomic lines they're not made out of
points they have points as boundaries so
these things i'll call zero elements
which is just a name for points zero
dimensional elements form the boundaries
of one elements of one-dimensional
elements
and
adjacency is then you say one point is
next to the another if they're both
boundaries of one in the same atomic
line atomic one element
uh and so you can have one-dimensional
spaces made up of these atomic points
and atomic lines here are some examples
the one at the top is sort of what you
think of a kind of infinite
an infinite one-dimensional universe if
you keep going in both directions or the
little pentagon would be a closed kind
of spatial universe or it could even
branch off in that way
so that's one way to think about
building up
discrete structures
now what i've been developing which i
call full discrete geometry
has atomic elements of this sort of
every dimensionality up to the
dimensionality of the space so you've
got zero elements that are points one
demand one elements that are one
dimensional atomic lines two elements
that are
two-dimensional atomic surfaces and
they're bounded by one elements
three elements which are atomic volumes
they're bounded by two elements
and so on you could keep going if you
wanted to as far as we can tell the
space we live in is three-dimensional so
we don't need to go above that
so that's the basic idea but once you
have the basic idea there are just lots
of ways to realize it you have to make
choices
um
the most common choice of physicists who
think about this is to use what are
called simplexes once you get up to two
dimensions and three dimensions and so
on
a simplex is the simplest kind of object
of that dimensionality so a
two-dimensional simplex the simplest
two-dimensional structure is a triangle
and
a three-dimensional simplex the simplest
three-dimensional structure of this sort
is it is a tetrahedron
and you can keep going up if you want to
go up in higher dimensions so that's
what's normally done um that's not what
i've been doing
uh i've been thinking in a different way
that's a bit associated
back to euclid
so you think of a one-dimensional
element a point is a sorry zero
dimensional element a point a zero
element
if it moves in some direction it traces
out
a line a one-dimensional element
and if we take that line and then move
it in some other direction move the
whole line in another direction
that will trace out a two-dimensional
element but it'll sort of be a
quadrilateral
and if i take that quadrilateral and
move it in yet another direction another
dimension that'll trace out something
that looks like a cube more or less a
square based prism so here visually you
can see what i'm talking about the zero
element is the line if i move it i get a
one element if i move the one element i
get a two element that has these four
bounding edges and if i move the two
element down i get a three element like
that
and you should think again that the
the larger dimensional elements are not
made of points the the only points there
are are the ones indicated so
uh in the three element there are eight
of them and they form
the vertices but that's all there are
good
so if we want to now build a model of
space using this we have to figure out
how these elements are stuck together
in order to make our space
and i'm going to talk through almost all
this talk about two-dimensional space
just because it's easier and it's easier
to picture and easier to draw pictures
of but everything would go over
pretty much without change into
three-dimensional space
uh and so well how do i make
an obvious two-dimensional space out of
my atomic elements
the obvious thing to do is to to do what
you get from tiling a euclidean plane
with squares or quadrilaterals that is
you get something like this two space so
you've got a finite number of points
there there are the yellow dots you have
a finite number of lines they're the
things that connect the dots
you have a finite number of
uh two-dimensional elements two elements
there are 25 of them in this space
and that's
that's the geometry of it
could
the space we live in
be like that
so that's the question you want to ask
now the first thing to notice is that
these discrete spaces
have a natural kind of intrinsic
geometry to them
because they're discrete
they're only finitely many elements if
the space itself is finite so we saw in
the in the space i just showed you there
are only 25
uh
two elements only 25 of these squares
and
uh 36
0 elements and so on you can just count
them
and so there's a natural way to define
something like a geometry
if i wanted to find the distance between
one
point and another between one zero
element and another
the natural thing to do is to find the
shortest continuous path that connects
them
a continuous path would be
starting from this one
then you go along a one element to its
boundary then to another then to another
and you just count how many jumps
it takes at a minimum to get from here
to there and if you do that that gives
you what's generally called taxicab
geometry for the obvious reasons so this
should be something everybody can
understand here's my two space
the distance
between the two red dots
is the shortest continuous path
that connects them which consists of
three
one elements three little lines so you
could say that distance is three
and the distance between the two blue
dots is the shortest continuous path
that connects them
and that turns out to be a distance of
eight
but it it's no longer unique
what the shortest path is there are lots
of
paths of length eight that will get you
from the
one dot to the other so if you start at
the bottom you could go up five and then
over three or you could go over three
and then up five or you could go up and
over and up two and over and sort of
zigzag your way up but the shortest path
will be eight units long
so that gives us a kind of sense of
distance in this space and it's the
natural one you would attribute to it
now the thing to notice about this
intrinsic geometry
is that it doesn't look like euclidean
geometry at all
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas